BERGERON LOSES THAT DRAW.
RYAN PULOCK, NO TIP AVAILABLE
FOR PALMIERI, PITCHED BY PELECH
AGAIN.
KYLE PALMIERI, TIED UP BY JEREMY
LAUZON.
BERGERON WIDE OPEN.
CHARLIE McAVOY WILL SKATE IT
OUT.
AT THE LINE.
THEY CROSS ON SIDE.
THIS IS MARCHAND.
HE SCORES!
BRAD MARCHAND WINS IT IN
OVERTIME!
HE DOES IT AGAIN.
BRAD MARCHAND IN THE EARLY
STAGES OF OVERTIME AND THE
BRUINS LEAD THIS SERIES TWO
GAMES TO ONE.
>> Pierre: IT STARTED WITH A
DEFENSIVE PLAY BY BERGERON IN
HIS OWN ZONE.
STRONG IN HIS OWN NET.
HIGH BEHIND HIS OWN NET TO FIGHT
FOR.
LOOK AT BERGERON.
SEES IT, REVERSES IT.
NOW THEY CAN COME OUT WITH
MCAVOY.
HE'S GOT ALL THAT SPACE AND ALL
HE DOES IS DUMP IT OFF AND GO
FOR A CHANGE.
THIS IS JUST A SURPRISE SHOT BY
MARCHAND.
HE LET IT GO QUICKLY.
VALAMOV, WHO HAD BEEN SO GOOD IN
THIS GAME GOT SURPRISED BY THIS
SHOT.
AND MARCHAND WINS IT.
>> John: HIS THIRD CAREER
OVERTIME GOAL IN THE STANLEY CUP
PLAYOFFS.
ONE MORE TIME FROM A TOUGH
ANGLE, AND HE FINDS A WAY TO
BEAT SEMYON VALAMOV.
BRAD MARCHAND ON THE SPOT, THE
REACTION AT THE BENCH.
THE BRNS WIN THE SWING GAME OF
THIS SERIES.